There's something beautiful about interactive gameplay that draws young people in to thinking about complex topics like narrative design, like identity, like character building, like complicated storytelling that's not linear. And all of those things line up to common core standards, which is amazing. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology. I'm Kim Mills. This week we're continuing our two-part series on the human side of technology. In January, APA joined the Consumer Technology Association at CES, the world's largest technology trade show, for a series of discussions about how artificial intelligence, virtual reality, digital health apps, and other tech developments are shaping human behavior and about how psychological science can help shape more ethical and effective technology. Afterward, we caught up with some of the panelists for extended conversations.
互动游戏有一种奇妙的魅力，能吸引年轻人去思考诸如叙事设计、身份认同、角色塑造以及复杂而非线性的故事讲述等复杂主题。所有这些都与共同核心标准不谋而合，这太棒了。欢迎收看《心理学话语》。我是金·米尔斯。本周我们将继续推出关于科技的人性化方面的两部分系列节目。今年1月，美国心理协会（APA）携手消费技术协会（CTA）亮相世界最大的科技贸易展——国际消费电子展（CES），就人工智能、虚拟现实、数字健康应用和其他技术发展如何塑造人类行为，以及心理学如何帮助塑造更具道德和更高效的技术展开了一系列讨论。会后，我们与部分小组讨论嘉宾进行了深入交流。
This week, we're bringing you our discussion with developmental psychologist Dr. Susan Rivers, executive director and chief scientist at I Thrive Games, a nonprofit organization that develops video games to advance teens' mental health and social emotional learning. Before joining I Thrive, Dr. Rivers served on the research faculty at Yale University for over a decade and was a co-founder of the Yale Center for Emotional Intelligence. I talked with her about why video games can be such an effective vehicle to reach kids, how to design games that are both entertaining and educational, and how parents can balance screen time concerns with a recognition of the important role
本周，我们将为您播出与发展心理学家苏珊·里弗斯（Susan Rivers）博士的访谈。她是“我成长游戏”（I Thrive Games）的执行董事兼首席科学家，“我成长游戏”是一个致力于开发旨在促进青少年心理健康和社交情感学习的视频游戏的非营利组织。在加入“我成长游戏”之前，里弗斯博士曾在耶鲁大学研究教职部门任职十多年，并且是耶鲁大学情感智能中心的联合创始人之一。我与她探讨了为什么视频游戏能够成为接触孩子们的有效途径、如何设计兼具娱乐性和教育意义的游戏，以及父母如何在对屏幕时间的担忧与认识到这些游戏在孩子生活中所扮演的重要角色之间取得平衡。
these games can play in their kids' lives. Here's our discussion. If you want to hear more from Dr. Rivers and the other psychologists who spoke at CES, you can find all the talks at cES.APA.org. Dr. Rivers, I want to thank you for joining me today here at CES. It's really great that you were able to join us and be on a panel here with us this afternoon. And we're going to talk a little bit about what you do as the head of an organization that creates games, gaming for good. And your organization is I Thrive Games.
以下是我们的访谈内容。如果您想收听里弗斯博士以及在CES上发言的其他心理学家的更多内容，您可以在cES.APA.org上找到所有的演讲。里弗斯博士，我想感谢您今天在CES上接受我的采访。非常高兴您能来到这里，并于今天下午与我们一同参加小组讨论。我们接下来将聊聊您作为一家游戏创作机构负责人的工作——寓教于乐的游戏。您的组织是“我成长游戏”。
I want to know what is gaming for good and why are video games a good way to teach kids and teens social, emotional skills and mental health lessons? Great, good questions. It's such an honor to be here. I had such a great time on the panel, so thank you very much for inviting me to be here with you today. So gaming for good is really how do we think about and design games that support young people in their development towards thriving? And so how do we, one, design learning experiences or just experiences? I think most experiences are learning experiences that integrate, knowledge and understanding the science of the teen brain, the science of where teens are in terms of their mental health, their learning, their identity formation, the importance of social relationships into the design of a digital experience for them that invites them to interact with a game space with other players that, one, helps them discover who they are and what they like
我想知道，什么是寓教于乐的游戏？为什么视频游戏是向儿童和青少年传授社交、情感技能以及心理健康课程的好方法？太好了，好问题。很荣幸能来到这里。我在小组讨论中度过了一段非常美好的时光，非常感谢您邀请我今天来这里。因此，“寓教于乐”实际上是指我们如何思考和设计能够支持年轻人朝着蓬勃发展方向成长的游戏？那么，我们如何一方面设计学习体验或仅仅是体验？我认为大多数体验都是学习体验，它们将知识和理解融入其中——青少年大脑科学、青少年在心理健康、学习、身份认同形成、社交关系的重要性等方面的科学知识——并将其融入数字体验的设计中，邀请他们与游戏空间和其他玩家互动，一方面帮助他们发现自己是谁以及自己喜欢什么。
different aspects of their selves that maybe they haven't explored before. Two, that brings some joy and where they have fun. Three, ideally, where they are interacting with others and forming memories together in that play space, getting to know each other, doing what matters in relationship, building, and connection. And also, I think that games are a really great place and gaming for good is a really great place
他们可能以前从未探索过自身的不同方面。第二，带来快乐并让他们获得乐趣。第三，理想情况下，他们能够与其他人互动，并在该游戏空间中共同创造回忆，相互了解，做关系建立和连接中重要的事情。同时，我认为游戏是一个非常棒的地方，“寓教于乐”也是一个非常棒的领域，
to really think about and design for the competencies that young people need to develop during adolescence and that they're really ripe to develop during adolescence and have a space to practice those in places that are in a space that is fun and where it invites failure because it's through failure that we learn. And so through failure we learn and we build
可以真正思考和设计年轻人青春期需要发展的能力，而他们正处于青春期发展的黄金时期，并且有一个空间在有趣且鼓励失败的地方练习这些能力，因为正是通过失败我们才能学习。因此，通过失败，我们学习并建立
and we go back at it and practice again And so that space of the digital space of play creates the opportunity to level up your skill set and get towards mastery in it. But that continuous development. Right, which is a classic feature of a game, how you keep people engaged, that you have to be working towards something. That's right. That's right. So one of the things that you said on the panel today was that you have to make games that don't feel like chocolate-covered broccoli. Yeah. How do you do that? How do you develop a game that is both entertaining and educational? Sure. So we are working in a space that is, you know, we're up front about learning and that kids actually do want to learn.
我们重新开始并再次练习。因此，游戏数字空间创造了提升技能水平并走向精通的机会。但这是一种持续的发展。没错，这是游戏的一个经典特征，即如何让人们保持参与，你必须朝着某个目标努力。没错。没错。因此，您今天在小组讨论中说过的一件事是，您必须制作不像是被巧克力包裹的西兰花的的游戏。是的。您是如何做到的？您如何开发一款兼具娱乐性和教育意义的游戏？当然。所以我们在一个这样的领域工作，你知道的，我们对学习持坦诚态度，孩子们其实确实想学习。
We don't hide that in the educational learning games that we create. We invite young people in to say, help us think about what are the skills that matter to them. What are the skills that they need in the world that they identify? but also that we see as being necessary for, whether it's English language arts or civics or democracy or looking at and evaluating the validity of media or fake news. And we work with them and we connect with them about what are some of the skills that you have, what do you think you need,
在我们创作的教育学习游戏中，我们并不掩饰这一点。我们邀请年轻人加入进来，让我们思考对他们而言重要的技能是什么。他们在自己认同的世界中需要什么技能？同时，这也是我们认为必要的技能，无论是英语语言艺术、公民学、民主，还是审视和评估媒体的有效性或虚假新闻。我们与他们合作，并就你们拥有哪些技能、你们认为自己需要什么与他们进行沟通，
how might you develop these, and then how can we create a context that's interesting and relevant to you? And so through that co-design process, we think about fun, we think about their strengths, and we design towards both of those within the context that we're working in, whether it's media literacy or relationship, healthy relationship building, whatever the context. And so we pair those things together and we continually bring content and aspects of the game to young people for their feedback. And they want to learn.
你们将如何培养这些技能，然后我们如何才能创建一个对你们有趣且相关的语境？因此，通过这种共同设计的过程，我们考虑乐趣，考虑他们的优势，并在我们工作的语境中针对这两者进行设计，无论是媒体素养、健康关系建立，还是任何其他语境。因此，我们将这些事情结合在一起，并不断向年轻人提供游戏的内容和方面，以征求他们的反馈。他们想要学习。
They want to develop these skills. and they want to be asked about how best to do it. And so it's through that partnership that we're able to create what's not chocolate-covered broccoli, but a meaningful, engaging learning experience. What about the vantage point of the educators who would be using these games?
他们希望培养这些技能，并希望被征求如何最好地做到这一点。因此，正是通过这种伙伴关系，我们才能够创造出不是被巧克力包裹的西兰花，而是有意义、引人入胜的学习体验。那些将使用这些游戏的教育工作者的视角又如何呢？
Where do you involve them in the process? We try to involve them all along the way as well. It's actually sometimes more difficult to get educators at the table. We put so much stress on our, educators in terms of the things we want them to be doing in the classroom, in school settings. We've had a lot of luck of bringing together educators to sit on advisory panels when we're launching a new game design project. We have a group of educators that we've been working with over the
你们在哪个环节让他们参与到这个过程中？我们尽量在整个过程中都让他们参与进来。实际上，邀请教育工作者参与有时更加困难。我们在教育工作者在课堂和学校环境中希望他们做的事情方面施加了太多的压力。我们在发起新的游戏设计项目时，曾多次成功地召集教育工作者加入咨询小组。我们有一个多年来一直合作的教育工作者群体，
years that we can call upon and ask for their advice or their input about how would you use this, would you use this, what would get in your way of using this game, what would you need to know? And we need to do a better job of that. We need to be reaching out to more and more educators as we do this. One of the challenges with inviting educators into use new technologies, they don't always have the systems in place that support them to be innovative, to take risks, to have classrooms that are allowed. Gameplay often elicits conversation and laughter and joy.
我们可以随时向他们咨询或征求他们的意见：你们会如何使用它？你们会使用它吗？使用这款游戏会遇到什么阻碍？你们需要了解什么？我们需要在这方面做得更好。随着我们开展这项工作，我们需要接触越来越多的教育工作者。邀请教育工作者使用新技术的挑战之一是，他们并不总是拥有支持他们进行创新、承担风险、拥有热闹课堂的现有系统。游戏玩法通常会引发对话、笑声和欢乐。
And schools often don't embrace that in the classrooms. So we'll keep it down, right? focus on the material. Let me talk to you or at you, and I'll tell you what you need to know. And bringing games into the classroom disrupts that. And that can be scary and frightening for adults in the space. Do you have examples of some favorite games that you would share with us? Sure. So I'm trying to think, should I choose some of the games that we've built or other games that are out there. A little of both. I'll start with one that we used in one of our first curriculum that we created. So I was really surprised to see when I came to I Thrive about eight years ago
而学校往往不接受课堂上有这种情况。因此，我们会说保持安静，对吧？专注于材料。让我对你说话或对着你说话，我会告诉你你需要知道的事情。将游戏引入课堂打破了这种模式。对于这个领域的成年人来说，这可能会让人感到害怕和恐惧。您有没有什么喜欢的游戏例子可以与我们分享？当然。让我想想，我应该选择我们自己制作的游戏还是其他现有的游戏。两者皆有一点。我先从我们创建的第一个课程中使用的游戏开始。所以大约八年前，当我来到“我成长游戏”时，我真的很惊讶地看到
where games had had gotten to. I grew up in the 80s and early 90s playing Donkey Kong and Frogger. We had Atari when I was growing up. So this is old school video games. And when you look at what's available right now, the catalog of beautiful games that are out there that are telling really rich, complex stories using really incredible graphics and visuals, but also storytelling techniques that invite players in to look at the world through a character's eyes or interact with belongings in a space as a way to do storytelling. So one of the games that we found early on is called What Remains of Edith Finch. This is an award-winning game.
游戏已经发展到了什么地步。我在80年代和90年代初长大，玩过《大金刚》和《青蛙过河》。我小时候有雅达利。所以这些是老派视频游戏。当你看看现在有什么时，那些精美的游戏目录正在通过非常不可思议的图形和视觉效果，以及将玩家吸引进来通过角色的眼睛看世界或与空间中的物品互动作为讲故事方式的讲故事技巧，来讲述非常丰富、复杂的故事。因此，我们早期发现的游戏之一叫做《艾迪芬奇的秘密》（What Remains of Edith Finch）。这是一款获奖游戏。
It's a storytelling game. and you sort of walk through this mansion that belongs to the main character, Edith Finch. And in each room in the mansion, you're looking to uncover, what is the story of the person who lived in this room? By looking at the artifacts they left behind, what can I discover about the story of this person? And so we, two things came up for us when we saw that. One is, what doesn't a person's identity even mean? And how could you understand a person's identity from the artifacts that are in,
这是一款讲故事的游戏，你穿梭于属于主角艾迪·芬奇的大宅中。在大宅的每个房间里，你都在试图揭开：住在房间里的这个人的故事是什么？通过查看他们留下的物品，我能发现关于这个人的故事的什么信息？因此，当我们看到这一点时，我们产生了两个想法。第一，一个人的身份究竟意味着什么？你如何从他们空间里的物品中了解一个人的身份？
their space and what stories can you tell and what richness is there in the context where a person resides and what's missing. And so in adolescence, there's such a richness of that work of identity formation that happens during the adolescent years that there's an immediate connection to looking at this game through the lens of who am I, who am I in who I present to the world, to the outside world, and who am I in my private spaces? And how do those go together and how do those sometimes not go together. And then that also linked up to looking at the ELA learning standards for high school in narrative storytelling, in describing place, and in many other things.
他们空间里的物品，你能讲出什么样的故事，一个人居住的语境中有什么样的丰富性，以及缺少了什么。因此，在青春期，身份认同形成的工作是如此丰富，这种工作发生在青春期，因此直接联系到通过我是谁的镜头来看待这款游戏，我在向世界、向外部世界展示时我是谁，以及在我的私人空间里我是谁。这些是如何结合在一起的，以及为什么有时它们并不结合。然后这也与查看高中英语语言艺术（ELA）关于叙事、描述地点以及许多其他方面的学习标准联系起来。
I mean, there were dozens of different lines from the Common Core, for example, that we could have pulled in as learning objectives for that. So that game created such a rich opportunity to talk about storytelling, to explore character and identity formation, but really give a hook to young people to have those really rich conversations in the classroom and prompt them to tell their own stories. So what remains to be a French is a fantastic game that tells stories, you're interacting with it, it's compelling, it's surprising, you're on edge when you're like a good mystery, when you're going through it, but opens the door to many different kinds of conversations.
我的意思是，例如，我们可以从共同核心标准（Common Core）中提取几十个不同的行作为学习目标。因此，这款游戏创造了一个如此丰富的机会来谈论讲故事，探索角色和身份的形成，但真正为年轻人提供了一个吸引点，让他们能够在课堂上进行那些真正丰富的对话，并促使他们讲述自己的故事。所以《艾迪芬奇的秘密》是一款奇妙的游戏，它讲述故事，你可以与之互动，它引人入胜，令人惊叹，当你经历它时，就像经历一个好的神秘故事一样紧张，但它为许多不同类型的对话打开了大门。
And depending on who you're playing it with, lots new conversations will happen because everyone will find a different piece that really connects to them. And that's where the richness and that relationship building happens. So we really love that game. So how does that then tie in with the learning objectives that the teacher might have? Yeah. So that's where the English language arts learning standards come in. So whenever we design, whether we're pulling a game off the shelf that someone else is created or we're designing one with a partner, we look to see, and this is where we work closely with a partner, we look to see, and this is where we work closely with a, educators, what do you need to teach? Not how do you need to teach it, but what do you need to
根据你和谁一起玩，会有很多新的对话发生，因为每个人都会找到真正与自己产生共鸣的不同部分。这就是丰富性和关系建立发生的地方。所以我们真的很喜欢这款游戏。那么，这与老师可能拥有的学习目标是如何联系起来的呢？是的。这就是英语语言艺术学习标准发挥作用的地方。因此，无论我们是挑选别人创作的现成游戏，还是与合作伙伴共同设计游戏，我们都会看看——这也是我们与合作伙伴密切合作的地方——我们看看，这也是我们与教育工作者密切合作的地方，你需要教什么？不是你需要如何教，而是你需要教什么？
teach? What's the core thing you need to teach when you're teaching the Cold War, when you're in history class, or when you're teaching about the amendments of the Constitution? And so we look at national standards. We look at state standards for that. And we do interviews with teachers to identify what learning objectives do we need to hit in designing the game, but also the surrounds that go around the game. So how do you introduce the game? What preparation do you need to do before you play it. What really matters during game play? How do you want to set that up so that students are prepared to look for, understand, play
当你教授冷战、处于历史课或教授宪法修正案时，你需要教的核心内容是什么？因此，我们查看国家标准。我们查看为此制定的州标准。我们对教师进行访谈，以确定在设计游戏时我们需要达到的学习目标，以及围绕游戏的周边内容。例如：你如何介绍游戏？在游玩之前你需要做哪些准备？游戏过程中什么才是真正重要的？你希望如何进行设置，以便学生准备好寻找、理解、体验
with the core thing that you're really looking for them to learn and understand and unpack? And then how do you, what's the campfire post game? Meaning after you've played, what do we talk about? How do we talk about what's in there? And so those learning objectives become the thread throughout both the design process of the game itself or in selecting the game, as well as the curricular surrounds that we build within four teachers to use in the space. So how does this work in a classroom? Does the classroom need to have some kind of a big screen TV that every kid is looking at and then they're playing at their
你真正希望他们学习、理解和剖析的核心内容？然后你如何——游戏后的“篝火晚会”是什么？这意味着在你玩过之后，我们谈论什么？我们如何谈论其中的内容？因此，这些学习目标贯穿于游戏本身的设计过程或游戏选择中，以及我们为教师在空间中使用而构建的课程周边内容中。那么这在课堂上是如何运作的？课堂需要有什么样的大屏幕电视，每个孩子都在看，然后他们在课桌上玩吗？
desk? I mean, how does it work in real life? Yeah, so every classroom is different. Many classrooms have things like smart boards and projectors. So, and sometimes they just have one computer or one device to play on. And so a lot of the work that we've done around supporting teachers to bring games into their classroom are play guides. So if your classroom setup has A, B, and C, here's what you can do. If you have X, Y, and Z, here's what you can do. If you have none of those things, here's some other options.
我的意思是，它在现实生活中是如何运作的？是的，每个课堂都是不同的。许多课堂都有智能白板和投影仪等设备。所以，有时他们只有一个电脑或一个设备来玩。因此，我们围绕支持教师将游戏引入课堂所做的大量工作都是游戏指南。因此，如果你的课堂设置有A、B和C，你可以这样做。如果你有X、Y和Z，你可以这样做。如果你这些都没有，这里还有其他一些选项。
And so sometimes they do group gameplay where one person has the controller, one student in the classroom has a controller and everyone else is watching. And often the watchers get more into it than even the person at the control. trailer. So setting up the context right is really important. Sometimes they play at home as part of homework and then they bring in, you know, things to talk about. So there's lots of different options. A lot of classrooms do have Chromebooks. So we always design for Chromebooks. A lot of students have their cell phone. So we also, when we're building our own games, we often design for mobile so that students can use what they have in the classroom. But it's definitely a challenge because every
因此，有时他们会进行小组游戏，其中一个人拿着手柄，课堂上的一个学生拿着手柄，其他人都在看。通常观看的人比拿着手柄的人更加投入。因此，正确设置语境非常重要。有时他们在家里作为家庭作业的一部分玩，然后他们带来（你知道的）要谈论的事情。所以有很多不同的选项。许多课堂都有Chromebook。因此我们总是为Chromebook进行设计。许多学生有手机。因此，当我们构建自己的游戏时，我们通常也会为移动端进行设计，以便学生可以在课堂上使用他们拥有的设备。但这绝对是一个挑战，因为每个
Every school is really different in terms of what access they have to resources and the level of broadband or the different things that they, you know, allow or prohibit bringing into the school. That raises the question of another topic that you talked about on the panel, which had to do with the roadblocks that you're getting from educators. How are you getting around these roadblocks? What is it that you could do to make things easier? Are you working with teachers unions, associations of principles? I mean, how do you kind of convince people that this is an effective route for teaching children important things? Yeah, we have a lot more work to do in that space, for sure. We are a really small team, and we are designers.
每个学校在资源获取、宽带级别或他们（你知道的）允许或禁止带入学校的不同事物方面真的非常不同。这就引出了你在小组讨论中谈到的另一个话题，这与你从教育工作者那里遇到的阻碍有关。你们是如何绕过这些阻碍的？你能做些什么来让事情变得更简单？你们是否在与教师工会、校长协会合作？我的意思是，你如何说服人们这是一条向儿童传授重要事物的有效途径？是的，我们在那个领域还有很多工作要做，这是肯定的。我们是一个非常小的团队，我们是设计师。
We're designers first. And we're always thinking about how can we design something that will be used in the classroom that really matters to us. And there are so many barriers in the way. And so what we've started to do is work with organizations that have either inroads into classrooms themselves or are working with young people outside of the school space. So in community spaces or direct to teen access to games and really thinking about how can we design what's best for that, for the different environments or contexts that our partners are working in. And then they are responsible for making sure it works in.
我们首先是设计师。我们一直在思考如何设计一种能够在课堂上使用且对我们真正重要的东西。而这其中有太多的障碍。因此，我们开始做的是与那些本身就能进入课堂，或者在学校空间之外与年轻人合作的组织合作。因此，在社区空间或直接面向青少年的游戏获取渠道中，认真思考我们如何为合作伙伴正在工作的不同环境或语境设计出最好的东西。然后他们负责确保它在
the spaces they're in. A lot more work needs to be done in helping school communities, the organizations that run schools, you know, administrators, school boards to really understand the value of games in learning and the potential for games and learning because there's so many systemic structures in the way of teachers being able to play with games in the classroom and really leverage their power for engagement. And, you know, there's the saying of people who work in schools, once you've been to one district, you've been to one district, you've been to that one district, every district is really so different
他们所处的空间中发挥作用。在帮助学校社区、运营学校的组织（管理员、学校董事会）真正理解游戏在学习中的价值以及游戏在学习中的潜力方面，还需要做更多的工作，因为在教师能够真正在课堂上玩游戏并真正利用它们的力量来促进参与的道路上有太多的系统性结构。而且，你知道的，在学校工作的人中流传着这样一句话：去过一个学区，你就去过一个学区，你就去过那一个学区，每个学区真的都是如此不同
and has different needs and requirements and budget constraints. So many organizations that are designing games or different tech for schools really run into a lot of barriers trying to make that happen. A lot of parents are concerned that their children are already spending a whole lot of their free time playing games. Is that another barrier you're facing where parents are saying, I don't want my kid to go to school to play games. He's already playing games all night at home.
并且有不同的需求、要求和预算限制。许多设计游戏或针对学校的不同技术的组织在试图实现这一目标时确实遇到了很多障碍。许多父母担心他们的孩子已经把大量的空闲时间花在玩游戏上了。这是你们面临的另一个障碍吗，家长们会说，我不想让我的孩子去学校玩游戏？他在家里整晚都在玩游戏。
Yeah, absolutely, absolutely. I think that we have this. Games have a dirty reputation, I think, in our culture of being a waste of time, not useful. You know, why can't you do something else important? And I think that some of that, there is some truth to some of that. And where I get to is, well, let's get curious. Why are our kids playing games a lot?
是的，绝对是，绝对是。我认为我们有这个。我认为游戏在我们的文化中有一个糟糕的名声，被认为是在浪费时间，没有用处。你知道，你为什么不能做其他重要的事情？而且我认为其中一些，其中一部分确实有其真相。而我的做法是，好吧，让我们保持好奇。为什么我们的孩子花很多时间玩游戏？
Why are they on their phones or why are they on their gaming platform instead of doing something else? Let's get curious and ask them. And when I've asked my children those questions, it really varies. Sometimes they're bored. And so then we have conversations about, well, what else could we do? What would really get you energized? What would be another choice that you have? or what can we do together so that you're not bored
为什么他们盯着手机或游戏平台而不是做别的事？让我们保持好奇并问问他们。当我问我的孩子这些问题时，答案真的各不相同。有时他们感到无聊。然后我们就开始讨论，好吧，我们还能做什么？什么能真正让你充满活力？你还有什么别的选择？或者我们能一起做些什么，这样你就不会感到无聊
and turning to something sort of mindlessly. Other times, I have a son who plays a lot of games. He's hanging out with friends. So they are parallel playing inside Fortnite or another game, and they're having lots of side conversations. And that's how a lot of people hang out. They have, you know, interesting, emotional, or fun or, you know, just catching up conversations
并且漫无目的地转向某些东西。其他时候，我有一个经常玩游戏的儿子。他和朋友们在一起。因此他们在《堡垒之夜》或其他游戏里进行平行游戏，他们有很多插话交谈。这就是很多人聚会的方式。他们进行了（你知道的）有趣、充满情感、好玩或只是叙旧的对话
while they're doing something else. And that's really important. And I don't want to take that away from my son, because that matters to him. He's also figuring stuff out, like, how would I build this game? How does this mechanic work? How do I get better at doing whatever, the building or the jumps or the complicated mechanics of this game?
当他们在做别的事情的时候。这真的很重要。我不想剥夺我儿子的这一权利，因为这对很重要。他还在琢磨一些事情，比如：我该如何构建这款游戏？这个机制是如何运作的？我如何才能更好地完成诸如建造、跳跃或这款复杂游戏的机制之类的事情？
So he's also pushing himself to develop more and more skills. And I see that play out in his storytelling, how he thinks about the world, how he builds things in his own outside of the game space. And so I think getting curious about how, why our kids are turning to games, not chastising them for choosing games is something. spending time on. Because when we do that, if it's something they really care about and they connect to or they identify with, if we tell them it's a waste of time, we're sending them the message that we don't value what's important to them, that we don't see the intrinsic value that
因此，他也在鞭策自己培养越来越多的技能。我看到这种表现体现在他的讲故事、他对世界的看法、他在游戏空间之外如何建造东西上。因此，我认为对我们的孩子为何转向游戏保持好奇，而不是因为他们选择游戏而责备他们，是值得花时间去做的事情。因为当我们这样做时，如果这是他们真正关心并与之产生共鸣或认同的事情，如果我们告诉他们这是在浪费时间，我们就是在向他们传达这样一个信息：我们不重视对他们而言重要的事情，我们看不到内在的价值
they see in this thing. We're judging it, and they'll internalize that. And that's really dangerous. We don't want to do that. So there's, I think, having a healthy balance of gameplay and non-gameplay time, but let's not criticize our kids for playing games. Let's get curious. Let's play with them. Let's have them teach us how to play. Let's discover what they love about it. How do you pick your games? How do you learn how to play? How do you figure out what you're going to play with your friends as a way to get to know them, as a way to get to spend time with them? How do you use your background as a psychologist to develop good games? What are you relying on that you learned in grad school and in your work subsequent to that? Every day I put.
他们在这个事物中看到了价值。我们在评判它，而他们会内化这种评判。这真的很危险。我们不想这样做。因此，我认为要保持游戏时间和非游戏时间的健康平衡，但我们不要批评我们的孩子玩游戏。让我们保持好奇。和他们一起玩。让他们教我们怎么玩。去发现他们为什么热爱它。你是如何挑选游戏的？你是如何学会玩的？你是如何弄清楚你要和朋友玩什么来作为一种了解他们的方式，作为一种花时间陪伴他们的方式的？你是如何运用心理学背景来开发好游戏的？你在研究生院以及随后的工作中依靠的是什么？每天我都会投入
on things that I've learned over the last 25 years as a social psychologist in the space of emotional intelligence and social emotional learning, it fuels good design. And so a really compelling game understands what feelings the player needs to feel to really deeply engage with the content or the game mechanics. And so in the design choices that my team and I are making in the games that we're creating, I'm really thinking about what's the emotional journey that we want to bring our young people on in this game? What kind of cognitive process do we want them to activate in this?
我在过去25年中作为一名社会心理学家在情感智能和社交情感学习领域学到的知识，它推动了好设计的诞生。因此，一个真正引人入胜的游戏了解玩家需要感受什么样的情感，才能真正深入地投入到内容或游戏机制中。因此，在我和我的团队在我们正在创作的游戏中所做的设计选择中，我真的在思考：我们希望在这款游戏中带给年轻人什么样的情感之旅？我们希望他们在其中激活什么样的认知过程？
Is there too much happening? And so they can't dig into the details or is there not enough happening so that they can't brainstorm? So what are the behaviors or thinking processes or feelings that are important in this moment in the game? And then how do we design with that in mind to make the design,
是不是发生了太多事情，以至于他们无法深入细节，或者发生的事情不够多，以至于他们无法进行头脑风暴？那么，在游戏的这个时刻，哪些行为、思维过程或情感是重要的呢？然后我们如何以此为基础进行设计，做出设计选择，帮助玩家进入这种状态。同时，我们也关注：我们希望学习者在游戏中培养、克服或练习的技能是什么？因此，你知道的，转向关于自我调节的文献，或者转向关于管理压力的文献，或者压力对决策有什么影响。好吧，我们希望年轻人学会使用流程做出深思熟虑的决策。好吧，他们能在没有压力的情况下做到这一点吗？
choices that help to fuel that state for the player. But also, what are the skills that player that we want our learners to develop and work through or practice in the game? And so, you know, turning to the literature on self-regulation or turning to the literature on managing stress or what does stress do to decision-making. Okay, we want our young people to learn how to make thoughtful decisions using a process. Okay, can they do that without stress? And, then can they do that with stress? And so we look towards the scientific findings for the different kinds of impacts external events have on emotions, the game processes, and use that in game design, but also what are
然后，他们能在有压力的情况下做到这一点吗？因此，我们研究科学发现，了解外部事件对情感的不同影响、游戏过程，并将其用于游戏设计，同时也研究年轻人需要具备哪些技能才能完成与心理健康、学习内容、成为外交官相关的任务。我们目前正在制作一款关于外交的游戏，并在游戏中训练年轻人如何成为外交官。很多人都可以使用那个。非常有趣。是的。那么，你们是如何招募游戏评论员的？
the skills a young person needs to be able to do a thing related to mental health, related to learning content, related to becoming a diplomat. We're building a game right now on diplomacy and training young people how to be diplomats in this game. A lot of people could use that. A lot of fun. Yes. So how do you recruit your game reviewers?
我的意思是，我是代表可能感兴趣的听众问的。可能会有一些人听了这个podcast说，哇，我真的很想（你知道的）参与进来，并对这些游戏的开发有发言权。是的，太棒了。我们一直在寻找年轻人来和我们一起进行游戏测试和设计。因此，我们有一个青少年中心，我们在那里接触并招募年轻人成为我们的专家。因此，我们将通过以下方式让他们参与：我们进行在线头脑风暴、游戏测试、原型设计环节，我们将游戏概念带给他们，他们对其进行剖析并帮助我们重建它们。或者我们会深入其中。
I mean, I'm asking for our listeners who may be interested. There could be some people who are listening to this podcast saying, wow, I'd really like to, you know, get in on this and have a hand in how these games are developed. Yeah, great. We are always looking for young people to play test and design with us. And so we have a teen hub where we reach out and recruit young people to be experts for us with us. And so we will engage them through, we do online brainstorming, playtesting, prototyping sessions where we bring game concepts to them and they tear them apart and help us build them back up. Or we will go into it.
我们上周五刚刚在纽约皇后区的一个教室里，我们带来了目前正在制作的冷战游戏的一个片段。即该游戏的两个幕。这是一个三幕游戏。我们将他们分组进行游戏，他们通关了游戏，我们观察他们玩游戏以查看：他们觉得无聊吗？他们看到了我们希望他们看到的东西吗？
We were just in a classroom on Friday in Queens, New York, and we brought a slice of the Cold War game that we're building right now. So two acts of that game. It's a three-act game. and we set them up in gameplay groups, and they played through it, and we watched them play to see. Were they getting bored? Were they seeing the things we wanted them to see?
他们是以我们希望他们互动的方式互动的吗？然后他们给了我们一大堆反馈。这很棒，改一下这个。我不喜欢那个。不确定在这里做什么。然后所有这些都被纳入了我们正在进行的对游戏的改进中。因此，从我们试图想出游戏的新想法，到我们拥有用于测试和收集反馈的原型，整个过程中的每一个环节
Were they interacting in the way that we wanted them to interact? And then they gave us a whole bunch of feedback. This was great, changed this. I didn't like that. Weren't sure what to do here. And so that was all then folded into the refinements on the game that we're doing. So all along the way from when we're trying to come up with a new idea for a game, to when we have a prototype that we're testing and collecting feedback on.
我们总是需要年轻人和我们一起做这项工作。我们非常珍视他们带来的经验和专业知识。无论如何，我们都会为他们的时间付费。他们是专家。我们需要他们的意见。因此，我们确保通过为他们的时间付费来验证他们给我们的意见，就像我们期望在为其他人提供项目专业知识时获得报酬一样。
We always need young people to do that work with us. And we really value the experience that they and the expertise that they bring to us. We pay them for their time no matter what. They're experts. We need their input. And so we make sure that we are validating the input that they're giving us by paying them for their time, just as we would expect to be paid if we are providing expertise on a project for someone else.
我们还确保我们的设计——无论是游戏测试还是头脑风暴环节——都能为年轻人带来情感之旅和学习之旅，无论是45分钟还是三个小时，我们都希望他们在整个过程中学到一些东西，无论是头脑风暴技巧还是应对针对特定技能集进行设计的不同方法。我们在思考如何能够在他们付出如此多的注意力和专业知识的同时，回馈给他们一些东西。我要问一个非常古怪的问题，也许我们会扔掉，也许不会。我们现在在拉斯维加斯，人们到处都在玩游戏。
We also make sure that we are designed, that whatever the play test or brainstorming session is has an emotional journey and a learning journey for the young people, whether it's 45 minutes or three hours, we want them to learn something throughout that process, whether it's brainstorming techniques or different ways to grapple with designing for a specific skill set. We're really thoughtful about how can we be giving something to them while they're giving us so much of their attention and expertise. I'm going to ask a really wacky question that maybe we'll throw out, maybe we won't. We're here in Las Vegas where people are playing games everywhere.
你们在观察这些人都在做什么吗？这些游戏有任何价值吗？好问题。所以游戏化（gamification）和游戏（gaming）是有区别的。而且，至少我使用这些术语的方式是非常不同的。因此，我认为游戏化就是拉斯维加斯的全部内容。我们如何不断激活玩家，让他们想要更多、玩更多、不放弃、继续把钱交给我们？
Are you observing what these people are doing? And are these games of any value whatsoever? Great question. So there's a difference between gamification and gaming. And so, and the way that I use those terms, at least, is very different. So I see gamification as what Vegas is all about. How do we continually activate the player to get them to want more, to play more, to not give up, to continue to give us our money?
因此，这个系统在这个空间里——我希望当我们坐在拉斯维加斯时不会有闪电劈下来——真的是在欺骗玩家，对吧？创造乐趣，创造互动，但也
And so the system in this space, and I hope that lightning bolts are not going to come down as we sit in Las Vegas, are really about cheating the player, right? Creating fun, creating interaction, but also. wanting them to lose so we get their money, right? And there's a lot of different kinds of games that are out there that are using and exploiting the reward system that, especially for young people, they really are looking for external rewards and they're really activated by that. And so I don't like that.
希望他们输掉，这样我们才能得到他们的钱，对吧？市面上有很多不同类型的游戏，它们在利用和剥夺奖励系统，尤其是对年轻人而言，他们确实在寻找外部奖励，并且被此深深激活。所以我不喜欢这样。
I don't think that's a good use of game mechanics. I think it's not very sophisticated how it's playing out, but it's not very interesting. It's not very creative. And it's not setting up a space that really supports young people in all of their vulnerability and all of their potential. And so when I think about gaming, I think gaming, especially in the space of gaming for good, and even just gaming for fun,
我认为这不是对游戏机制的良好运用。我认为它在表现上不是很成熟，但也不是很有趣。它不是很具创造性。而且它没有建立一个真正支持年轻人所有脆弱性和所有潜力的空间。因此，当我想象游戏时，我认为游戏，尤其是在寓教于乐的领域，甚至只是为了好玩的游戏，
that we have the potential to captivate a person's attention for a specific period of time. How can we make it the most meaningful experience for them? that helps them build something, helps them develop a skill, helps them have an aha experience where they have an insight about who they are and what they're about in the world, or have an insight about someone else that they're interacting with in the game,
我们有潜力在特定时间内吸引一个人的注意力。我们如何能为他们打造最有意义的体验？帮助他们建立一些东西，帮助他们培养一项技能，帮助他们获得“啊哈”体验，让他们对自己在世界上的身份和所作所为有深刻的见解，或者对他们在游戏中与之互动的其他人有深刻的见解，
whether it's in real life or a character in the space. So I think there's so much more creativity that happens in the gaming space versus the gamification space that pulls on so much of the, and translates the, the science of psychology to really unpack and tap into human experience and help in that young people thrive. So that's what we're about.
无论是在现实生活中还是空间里的角色。因此，我认为与游戏化空间相比，游戏空间中发生了更多的创造力，它汲取了大量的心理学科学知识并进行转化，以真正剖析和挖掘人类体验，并帮助年轻人蓬勃发展。这就是我们的宗旨。
That's what I get excited about. You mentioned that you're working on a game about the Cold War. Anything else in the offering that you want to preview here? Yeah, so I'm really excited about our Cold War game. We're doing a six-week unit on the Cold War that culminates in this Cold War simulation. And so students, players in that, curricular unit, high school students will develop their skills for diplomacy and they won't
这也是让我兴奋的地方。你提到你正在制作一款关于冷战的游戏。还有什么其他想要在这里预览的项目吗？是的，我对我们的冷战游戏感到非常兴奋。我们正在做一个关于冷战的为期六周的单元，最终以冷战模拟结束。因此，学生、该课程单元中的玩家、高中生将培养他们的外交技能，他们不会
just write about them and they won't just think about it. They'll have to enact them in a real world simulated experience. Really excited about that. We're also putting the finishing touches on a project we've been working on with Department of Homeland Security through funding from them to think about this space of young people who are recruited into violent extremist organizations and And how do we, it's supporting young people and identifying the early signs of that recruitment that happens in a lot of these online spaces. It's a real, really upsetting space. And young people are especially vulnerable to someone, especially when they're feeling
只是写下来，他们不会只是思考。他们必须在现实世界的模拟体验中将其实施。对此感到非常兴奋。我们还在为我们与国土安全部合作的项目做收尾工作，资金来自他们，旨在思考这样一群年轻人：他们被暴力极端主义组织招募，以及
vulnerable themselves or feeling like they don't belong, which so many of our young people do. We all did when we were young, too. It's a part of adolescence. and that vulnerability is being exploited by these recruitment organizations and that can lead to really bad outcomes for young people and communities. And so in this game, we're really looking at how do we help young people who are observing that happening to a friend or someone they know and give them the tools to potentially
我们如何——它支持年轻人识别在许多这些在线空间中发生的招募的早期迹象。这是一个非常、非常令人沮丧的空间。当年轻人感到脆弱或觉得没有归属感时，他们特别容易受到别人的影响，我们的很多年轻人都是这样。我们年轻时也一样。这是青春期的一部分。这种脆弱性正被这些招募组织所利用，这可能会给年轻人和社区带来非常糟糕的后果。因此在这款游戏中，我们真正关注的是：我们如何帮助那些观察到这种现象发生在朋友或认识的人身上的年轻人，并为他们提供工具来潜在地
interrupt that process? What are the things you might say? What are some signs you can look for? how might you approach your your friend and say the right thing or say something that that might connect with them and help them choose a different different path well dr rivers i want to thank you for joining me here today i want to thank you for being part of APA's presence at cES true pleasure thank you so much you can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology on our website at www.
中断这个过程？你可能会说些什么？你可以寻找哪些迹象？你如何接近你的朋友并说出正确的话，或者说出能够与他们产生共鸣并帮助他们选择不同道路的话？好吧，里弗斯博士，我想感谢你今天加入我。我想感谢你成为APA出席CES的一员。真的非常荣幸，非常感谢你。你可以在我们的网站www.
speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Widenman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian.
speakingof psychology.org上，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学话语》以前的节目。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学话语》由李·维登曼（Lee Widenman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Kondyian）。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢收听。我是美国心理协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。